Jennifer Lawrence gets revenge on Chris
Pratt
while Chris explains his failed attempt
to impress a football pro I got nervous
I wanted him to be my friend
[Music]
are you the kind of person who's going
to take this let Chris keep this kind of
abuse on you I'm gonna do something
about you our justice was served on
Monday night's Jimmy Kimmel Live as
Jennifer Lawrence got revenge on her
passengers co-star Chris Pratt who's
been called Lee yet hilariously cropping
or covering Jen in his Instagram pics
[Music]
Jen and Jimmy had no mercy
spray-painting Chris's face the end
result was truly devilish meanwhile
Chris was across town on The Late Late
Show with James Corden where he revealed
what happened when he invited Green Bay
Packers quarterback Aaron Rodgers over
for a meal comes to your house yeah you
think I'm better I better man up here
you know yeah so I planned some manly
things does I desperately of course want
him to be my friend and I want him to
like me and so I said we'll do some
fishing I'll do a little barbecuing on
the grill but I seared it for like 20
minutes too long so yeah Chris epically
failed at grilling Aaron Rodgers a steak
but he explained it's only because he's
so starstruck by sports stars athletes
hundreds still we we get like on and I
got to go to the Seahawks game and we
got to meet like you know the athletes
like Richard Sherman you should have
seen on us she was so starstruck
[Music]